Christmas is more than a month away but
the holiday lights are already shining
at the Las Vegas Motor Speedway
glittering lights has returned for its
22nd year Candace Charles joins us live
from the speedway this morning with a
sneak peek I see you're still in your
reindeer PJs what's going on out there
Candice
well Sherry as you know it's cold
to grab their Cocos put on their nice
warm PJs and come on down to Las Vegas
speedway to get into holiday spirit as
you can see lots of lights were
glittering lights I'm going to show you
a little bit of one of the great
experiences going into the 12 Days of
Christmas have fun Stacy we're going for
a ride here's a little music from ho ho
ho
[Music]
still on there good guys so with a 2.5
mile course experience more than 5
million likes that's five million likes
and 600 displays new this year Larger
than Life Edition I like the glittering
lights no Yeti display and Las Vegas is
desert dogs professional lacrosse team
added the sports alley Classics like the
living nativity returns all select
nights of course and of course the Santa
tray on this back you guys but those
tickets do sell out quickly so you'll
want to go ahead and get those as soon
as possible look we're passing the dunge
I Love Christmas you guys as you can see
and if you forget your snacks don't
worry you can get kettle corn and hot
cocoa here as well begging for a holiday
family fun or a great date night you
heard that guys a great date night
experience and all is really for a
fairly affordable price tickets start at
just 29 what do you think Stacy a great
experience right come on down here with
your kids you guys it all starts today
runs all the way January 8th I got all
the details for you on our website
agnewsnow.com for now live from last
week's Speedway I'm Candice Charles turn
on your whole music now hang out with me
it is now
thanks again that was that was great
that was a wild ride yes and shout out
to Stacy for holding on to that golf
cart while she was mowing down at uh
light speed there strapped in all right